over the last few years we've seen
multiple Comics blow up online through
the use of crowd work Clips whether it
be Stavros Sam Morel or even Andrew
Schultz who famously started the whole
clip game by posting one video every
single week for a year posting crowd
work Clips helped all these guys gain
some popularity in the comedy space and
sell tickets on the road but it's still
nothing compared to the perfect internet
storm that hit Matt Wright it just all
One Clip just blew up everything it was
so weird it was one clip yeah a video I
thought was stupid and didn't want to
post anyways I was like this isn't even
funny a young handsome comedian's highly
sexual and funny crowd work clip goes
viral reaching audiences on the internet
that never in a million years would have
stepped foot in a comedy club unless
dragged by their boyfriends